phasmaphobia the early access horror
game has taken twitch and social media
by storm
for those uninitiated phasmaphobia's
goal is simple though
achieving it is a little tricky you
either alone or with a group of friends
play a ghost hunter investigating a
haunting and trying to determine which
type of ghost you're dealing with
as you explore the area you will need to
use a variety of tools to gather
evidence before the ghost
kills you aside from the scares and this
the most horrific thing about
phasmaphobia in its current state is the
lackluster tutorial
it teaches you the basics for a few
investigation tools but leaves a lot for
you to figure out on your own
so with that in mind let's go over what
you need to know about phasmophobia
[Music]
i can hear it i can hear it
[Music]
as i mentioned before your job is to
figure out what kind of ghost you're
dealing with to do that you need to
first
identify which part of the building the
ghost is haunting and then you need to
find three separate pieces of hard
evidence to log in your journal
once you've found three clues you can
select the ghost in your journal and
gtfo
i like to imagine the ghostbusters roll
through after you catch the ghost but
i'll save that for when i start writing
my phasmaphobia fan fiction
what happened are you okay he slimed me
that's great
actual physical contact in order to find
evidence you need to know how the tools
work and how to use them effectively so
let's run through your gear
the emf reader is one of the most
important pieces of tech in your tool
kit
turn it on as you explore the house and
monitor the levels on it while clearing
rooms
high emf readings don't necessarily mean
danger or high levels of paranormal
activity it simply means that a ghost
could be nearby or that you could be in
the haunted room the emf reader is very
useful early on as it can help you
pinpoint which room is the source of
paranormal activity
if the emf reader hits level 5 you can
log that as evidence in your journal
when you have a minute to breathe
the spirit box is one of the creepiest
tools in the game as it often requires
you to sit in a room by yourself with
the lights off and try to have a
conversation with the ghost using your
real world microphone
i recommend saving spirit box duty for
the last person in your group that loads
in
aka your friend without the ssd with the
spirit box your goal is to get the ghost
to respond to you directly you can do
this by asking questions such as how old
are you can you speak to me is there
anything with me and so on the ghost can
respond to your questions in one of two
ways it can interact with the
environment like turning off lights or
moving objects or it can respond
directly through the spirit box
if you hear it through the spirit box
then you can mark that down as a clue in
your journal if it moves an object that
means that the spirit is nearby but that
doesn't count as a clue you can log in
the journal
alternatively the spirit box may just
say nothing detected in which case you
should try a different room
if you don't get nothing detected but
haven't heard a voice keep talking
keep in mind that for the spirit box to
work the lights need to be turned off
and some ghosts will only respond to you
if you're alone
if you do end up with the spirit box
make sure you're holding down proximity
chat when you talk
technically the ghost can hear your mic
inputs even if you don't push to talk
but i recommend doing it anyway just in
[Music]
case
i consider the video camera a stage two
item since you can only carry three
tools at once flashlight included i'd
leave the camera in the van until you've
pinpointed the haunted room
once you know where the paranormal
activity originated from return to the
van and grab the video camera
the bigger black camera place the camera
in a corner of the room that will give
you the widest feel of view possible you
can hold left click to rotate the camera
right click to turn it on and
f to place it don't forget to turn it on
before you bail
the last thing you want is to walk all
the way back to the van only to find out
that you didn't turn on the camera oddly
enough in phasmaphobia the green light
means recording and the red means off so
make sure to check
after you've placed the camera you or a
crew member should return to the van and
look at the monitor
left clicking on the in-game mouse will
change the cameras and clicking on the
keyboard will toggle night vision
whoever is monitoring the cameras should
be looking for ghost orbs
ghost orbs look like fireflies that
flutter by the camera if you see an orb
make sure to log it in your journal as a
clue
if you don't see one it's usually good
to try another angle just to be thorough
alternatively you can purchase head
mounted cameras which don't take up an
inventory slot and function similarly to
the camera
like the camera the ghostwriting book is
a stage 2 item
once you know which room the ghost is
camping out in set up the journal and
wait
if writing appears on the book mark it
in your journal when you have the
journal make sure to press
f to place it and not g to throw it down
technically the ghost can write in the
journal no matter how it's positioned
but i like to keep it facing up so my
crew can clearly see the book and the
best way to do this is placing it with
f apparently the ghost can even write in
the journal while you're holding it but
i haven't witnessed that yet
the galaxy brain play here is to set up
the journal in the view of your video
camera so you can see it from the
comfort of the van
the uv flashlight isn't what you're
probably thinking instead of using it to
find mucky business you'll use it to
spot fingerprints
like the last few gadgets you can
probably leave the uv flashlight in the
van during the early stages of the job
typically fingerprints don't appear
until later once there's been a
significant amount of paranormal
activity grab the uv flashlight and
sweep the affected
areas the best places to find hand and
fingerprints are on doors and windows if
you see something snap a picture for
extra cash and mark it in your journal
the thermometer is the only tool that
isn't part of your default tool kit i
highly recommend bringing one of these
along no matter the job
this is a great tool to use for the
initial sweep of the house
if you see the temperature drop below 10
there's a good chance you are in the
affected room
if it drops below zero then you'll want
to add freezing temperatures to your
journal
if you forget a thermometer which will
almost certainly happen you can tell if
a room is freezing
if you can see your breath admittedly
the thermometer makes things a bit too
easy on smaller maps as it can be a
dead giveaway as to which room is
haunted on bigger maps though the
thermometer can save you a ton of time
while those are the most important tools
you use on any given job there are a
handful of other optional tools that you
can take with you
these include a crucifix which can
protect you from certain ghosts
smudge sticks which can calm a ghost and
sound sensors which can help you
pinpoint the ghost location
while those tools can help you gather
evidence they aren't as straightforward
as the tools i listed
if you're new to phasmaphobia i
recommend sticking with the tools i
discussed earlier and slowly trying out
new ones as you get more comfortable
with the basics
it's also worth noting that if you
successfully use some of these optional
tools you can make a little extra cash
when you finish the job
now that we've run through some basic
equipment let's get into some best
practices for when you're out in the
field
first i highly recommend using in-game
voice chat once you and your team have
found your footing discord is nice when
you're starting out but it makes things
a bit too easy and
far less terrifying
the game also does some fun things with
audio implementation that make the
experience more immersive intense
for in-game communication use v for
proximity chat and b for global chat
courtesy of the handy walkie-talkie
keep in mind that your walkie-talkie
isn't always super reliable though
during high paranormal activity your
signal could get scrambled
if you aren't near your crew you'll have
no idea what could be happening to them
you can check paranormal activity levels
from the monitor in your van
usually it's good to let your team know
if there are any spikes low amounts of
activity could mean flickering lights or
moving objects
moderate spikes could mean direct
contact with the ghost and level 10
spikes usually mean the ghost
is hunting was this this opened for half
a second closed
oh right here i could hear him oh god
the best thing you can do for them is to
pray if a level 10 spike just occurred
and someone sanity percentage is
replaced by a question mark it means
they're dead
and if you're using in-game chat dead
team members can't communicate with you
if you're in the house during a level 10
spike your flashlight will start to
flicker
the front door will lock and you may see
the ghost appear and disappear
if the ghost is weak to crucifixes you
can stop it from hunting by throwing it
on the ground
or at the ghost if not hide in another
room turn off the lights and stay quiet
closets do nicely for this if you're
dealing with a shy ghost you can try
using its name as well
typically ghosts will get more annoyed
the more you say it
before you head into the house check the
whiteboard in the van to see the ghost
name
and if it responds to everyone or just
those who are alone
with each paranormal activity you
witness your sanity will drop you can
monitor your sanity in the
truck the lower it goes the easier it is
for a ghost to target you
you can regain your sanity by using
sanity pills which are available to
purchase before a job
as you complete jobs earn money and
level up you'll unlock new maps and gear
to test out
any additional gear you purchase and
take into the field can be lost if you
die
so be extra careful if you want to hold
on to those thermometers and motion
sensors
you do get an insurance payout though so
it's not a complete loss
the bigger maps like the high school and
asylum may also force you to change up
your tactics
the best way to go about these jobs is
to split into groups and clear rooms
methodically
study the map in the van before you
leave come up with a game plan
and designate a regroup point for your
team if someone gets lost you can check
their location via the map in the van
and guide them to safety using the
walkie-talkie
sanity pills are typically a must on
these maps as they usually take much
longer than most house jobs
when you find the affected room leave a
glow stick outside the door or have
someone make a mental note of it on the
map in the van
there are also some cases where you
won't be able to find the third piece of
evidence no matter how hard you try
if you're really struggling you can
check the ghost descriptions in your
journal
this isn't always the most accurate way
to solve a case but if you're low on
supplies there's no harm in checking the
journal to see if there are any familiar
patterns
there you have it almost everything you
need to know about hunting ghosts and
phasmaphobia
if there's something i missed please
leave it in the comments below to help
out your fellow ghost hunters
and with that good luck out there
you